these are the top three differences
between MHC class 1 and MHC class 2. MHC
class 1 is present in any nucleated cell
whereas MHC Class 2 is present in all
professional antigen presenting cell
like dendritic cell
MHC class 1 and 2 differs in terms of
their structure class 1 has alpha 1
Alpha 2 and Alpha 3 chains and a beta2
microglobulin Class 2 MHC has alpha 1
and Alpha 2 Chain and another side beta
1 and beta2 chains then class 1 MHC
displays endogenous or viral peptides
Class 2 MHT displays generally exogenous
antigens
class 1 and Class 2 MHC are encoded by
different region in the genome so there
are different HLA clusters for each of
these class 1 and Class 2 MHC
watch the full video to know more follow
us on social media